foreign
yep Megan Fox is ready for Beach season
flaunting her summer bod on the gram the
other bathing suit pulls away from the
body that is insane just weeks after
landing the iconic Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit Issue what's a bucket list goal
and being on Sports Illustrated was
definitely one of those June Gloom looks
good on 37 year old who rocks a
two-piece black bikini in the snaps
she's shared over the weekend and you
were just bringing the baba boom yeah
he's trying we also noticed Meg seems to
have gotten a trim since gracing the
Magazine's cover last month and is that
a guitar we see over there hey would you
make of that camera
I have a lot of young Venus energy I
kind of describe it as like there's a
Girl Scout summer camp counselor inside
of me always when I lean into that in
nature and I'm in my youthful awe of
life that's when I feel by far the most
myself and then therefore I feel the
most sexy we'll be here first reaction
when S I called you to say we want you
to be one of our couple gal
um I think I had sort of manifested it a
few weeks earlier I had been like you
know I really think I should do the
cover of Sports Illustrated and then a
few weeks later they called and they
were like do you want me to cover a
Sports Illustrated I'm not a psychic but
I did you sound like a psychic yeah
Megan's talked a lot about her spiritual
side and get this her caption on the
photos ace of cups and the star
references to tarot cards I'm always
surprised at how I am eccentric and her
fans are surprised by the actress
getting candid inside the mag opening up
about her struggles with body dysmorphia
quote I don't ever see myself really the
way other people see me the first thing
anyone notices about someone is going to
have something to do with their physical
appearance it's inevitable you can't get
around to that there is never a point in
my life where I loved my body never ever
in what ways are you working on your
journey of self-love these days I've
sought throughout my life a lot of
different forms of therapy and right now
I do a lot of I prefer like metaphysical
approaches and holistic approaches to
Healing I have a vision in my head that
I'm like trying to achieve so we'll see
if it pans out for me
what I most want people to know is that
I'm a genuine Soul who is hoping to
actually belong to something and not
always have to live as a misunderstood
Outcast back in the Maddox profile Megan
says the Journey of loving myself is
going to be never-ending I have a lot of
people I
eyes with and I'm always reading books
and trying to learn more about myself
and trying to open up and I think for me
it's a lot about healing childhood
trauma because that's where the root of
that comes from for me so that's what
I'm working
I want all people not just women to have
respect for their bodies and and for
themselves